Candace Owens devoted a segment on her
show to this where she was almost in
tears over my tweet David Pacman does
not have a soul he doesn't have a soul
posting to Twitter quote more left-wing
filth David pakman is laughing at the
fact that the dead children are
Christians who believe in prayer these
are real tweets these people think it's
funny when Christian children die no I
think it's tragic when thoughts and
prayers are the only thing offered by
Republican officials
and she is even going after our
advertisers and this is where this is
getting genuinely bad I wish it wasn't
but it is Candace Owens adding to any of
your advertisers who may be following
this this is not a contrived mob or
anti-Semitism this is you dealing with
the consequences of sending the most
horrifically bigoted tweet directed at
dead Christian children who according to
you should have prayed harder of course
that's not the point